it's as gnarly as I could have imagined
it being just like this is a lot of
stuff I'm just really nervous about how
fast I'm gonna be actually flying off
the lip
with drop kayaking when you're really
pushing yourself is when you feel more
alive but it's
really dangerous waterfall running is
not something that everybody likes to
engage with
you come in with speed and then you
immediately go to a vertical free fall
you're going from 45 miles an hour to
dead stop
it feels like being whiplashed in a car
crash
[Music]
with day kids hitting your face with
your paddle breaking your nose
which is why we sometimes throw the
bottles
the benefit of throwing your paddle that
creates less chances of hitting yourself
with the paddle
with a hydraulic you have this curtain
of water that's hitting the pool and
it's pulling you down underwater
if you are in a hydraulic you can also
plate that and then the water will pull
you down and pop you Downstream
you got there if you go too far right
it have a really bad spot where it kind
of folds back in and you would just try
to just break your boat and die
the Rio Santo Domingo has this super
steep section that had never been done
before that's a complete top to bottom
descent
a crazy looking rapid man
before running a rapid you always
visualize the line
how are you gonna enter the current
where your reference points
I rock or a breaking wave
and where do you want to be on that lip
yeah we need a solid safety team down
there dude and the amount of people that
we have right now I'm not sure if it's
enough
on trips like this you have to trust
that your partners are going to be able
to potentially save your life
because in big drop kayaking you can
plan every move you can scout every line
but until you're in the water you don't
know exactly what's going to happen
foreign
the most important thing for me
is not getting hurt
I don't want that for my family
[Music]
okay
[Music]
what you guys reading
when I majored I started kayaking
he's been a good teacher and we've been
kayaking together ever since you got the
kids
kayaking gives you more mental strengths
because you're about to run something
that scares you
betrayed
I trust him a lot and I know that he
doesn't do stupid things but I worry all
the time I just don't tell him nice
let's go you ready
we have two tiny person at home that
they are waiting for him
and you always think that something bad
can happen
[Music]